voodoo
bea
me
a 中に自治労と申します
実は熊本県小城市の出身です
第6表15が上手になったでしょう
ね20年塗料入ってますでございました
私は今までへ
スピーカーでは難聴者の方は支援できないですと言われ続けています
そのことに対して
全職業栄光と会社でしたてそのチャレンジをしてみようと
思いまして富士に何とも常に頑張りましてスピーカーによって男女の方を支援できる製
品を世に送り出した
いう形でございますで
冤罪ではですね協議して大学なっているとか広島大学の方でまた同の研究
ね道で引き取っているかで研究をさせていただいております
写真は広島でよくも迫力している研究室の
f
局員平和性格
とって
切ってる俺に入りするね
微妙じゃないですよ
私の夢です
世界中の人と人
と思うのですねの本性コミュニケーションを快適なものに変えていくっていうのが私の
夢です
その夢のきっかけを与えてくれたら私はそうです
大事だとおばあちゃんです所しながらやはりネットともに聞こえがどんどん悪くなって
しまい
聞こえているのが聞こえていないのか私が話しこれでも
なが堪能してくれなくなりました僕が勝手にこちらは
もちろん安定に
心を開いだったかなと思う
とか今日はあまり話でございのかなって思ってた
あります
同じく実は父も男女でした
これは事故による感情なんですけども
ドライブに行って隣に座っているときにやはり聞こえませんので覚えた話をしなきゃ
いけない
テレビはなく土間コンでなっています
それでも見てて
子供ながらいいですが
戸祭 part なんでこんな大きな声で話さなきゃいけないんだろうと思う自分がい
ました
その質が私は機構の研究をしておりますが小さい頃は全く聞こえの理解がなかった
あの頃
もっと違う対応ができたと思います
聞こえのお話をさせていただいていますけれども聞こえというものはですね言葉では
なかなか理解できません
なので音でぜひ体験してみたいと思います
here リーグロスシュミレーターっていうアプリがあるんですけどもそちらで制作
したサンプルの講義を聴いていただきたいと思います
難聴は軽度
修道
高
縦横の4段階に分かれてますけども正常な聞こえの場合と中等度難聴の前とコードのか
この3つを聞いて頂きまし
それでは正常 no 聞こえの方お願いします
ちゃんと23
加藤さん
こちらが正常ですね続きまして秋冬
それでは最後に行動
どうでしょうか正常に比べて相当聞こえずらいですよね
保存だけだと
秋冬となりますのでマートのクラン飛行中くらい聞こえてるんでしょと思いがちなん
ですけどもこれ言えなくなります
研究を進めていく中で
やはりその課題が多くたり
土と気づいていきました最初から前職であるレコード会社からは
なぜお前は難聴者のためにこんな政治を作る沿い
言われますなぜ私が人のために頑張ろうとしている
2回シャツを言ってくるか正直わかりませんでした結局
連休は生きるストです
残念ながらですね非常に残念でした
その3
皆さんもよくご存知な東にも大震災が起きました
あのころです今日も私も良くお願いしてみました色なんですとが平均金を集めたり
いろんなところでコンサートしたりしてました否定しながら言われさんは音楽は無力だ
という言葉を言われました
私は絶対値がどうした音楽は絶対暴力ではない
そんな思いの中で浮かんだのが自分の仕事は
人のためになってるんだろうかという問いかけにすごく
感じるようになりましたどんどんどんどん悩んできました
で働くっていうも改めて考えてくれます
よく言われているのは働く=人が動く立てるとかそういった事を言われると思います
私はこの3つに感じは出ていました
人が重い力といいですね
この意味ですけれども
人の重きを取り入れることに力を注ぐこと
これが仕事ではないと
働くということではないかと思うようになってきたんですね
その中で私は友人と共に npo 法人を立ち上げました
ええ
学校は音楽を教えてくれます
しかしながら耳の仕組みや聞こえについてはまったく先生方も教えてくれません
それが分かりましたのでまずは
年長者の方が聞こえる方に対して軟調も正しい理解ですこれは誰からか皆さん理解して
いただいていますよ
それと作業いった聞こえを支援するスピーカーの研究療法の研究だしました
しかし今度は
南條者に聴覚障害者の方々から言われました
なぜあんたは聞こえとルビー
私たちの旅尽くしていると
なんかろくでもないも作っておりある向きだろうと言われまして
温度ができてるという論議かですね
しかしながら
これもよく言われました
何度も何度もう
挫折を繰り返しましたもうまた僕が研究していることは皆求めてないんじゃないかと
思った
女子だからこの言葉を難聴児のお母さん方からいただいたのです
聞こえにくいおや私たちのために一生懸命地下の注ぐをと舐めるだけでどんなね今私は
勇気付けられるか
この言葉を言われてっ
すいません
高校なども頑張ることができたと思います
を取る
励まされましたっ
またそんな中で研究してて気づいたことがあります
ヘアキラーよく皆さんご存知だと思いますコミュニケーションを取る際に相当努力をさ
れた方です
レギュラー持っています
目が見えるあると人ともの道は話していく
耳が聞こえなくなると人と人とお話してください
この言葉を聞いたことで私はひらめきました
また世の中ですけれどもこれを見ていただければわかると思いますけども見えにくい
ことへの配慮はあります
また
聞こえないことを主はだったら筆談ですね
はありますが聞こえにくいことへの対応は非常に遅れているということを分かって
いただけるでしょうか
メガネなんかはいろんなところにありますよ
家庭内です
世の中もう一回がありませんが実はこれよく言われます
難聴のを患ってしまったのおじいちゃんおばあちゃんですね
肉親なのにまったく私の聞こえにくいことをわかってくれ
なぜ身内なのにわからないだろうという言葉を掛けられます
あと大事だった話なら聞いてなかったとか
待てリレー先ほど言いますけどことも大きいたてますね
あと定例補助にをつけるかつけないかで一悶着とか
あとペンはかけてを持てない
いうことが家庭内でも起きています
また職場でも起きています
よく学生の方から相談を受けます私が左意味が電話でできないと聞こえに振って
これは電話はできないということを会社に有利なんでしょうか
言われます
非常に難しいですが言うべきなんかどうか迷うところですよね
りぎりが何とかなっている上期でやろうかって話
としていただくこともあります
あとは同僚に無視していると誤解されるんですね
はやっぱりなかなか言えないって言っても理解されないというものがあると思います
あとは会議やセミナーにも参加しにくいなかなか反応してくれないということをよく
聞きます
皆さん
今の聞こえが
運動
そのままだと
思っていませんか
年齢を重ねるごとに視力も低下します
お肌もお願いします
それと同様に聴力も低下するということをなかなか皆さん理解してません
ある日突然聞こえに船瀬はどうされますか
実は日本では年間3万5000人の方が
内情になってしまいそのうち2万3000人の方がいい
聴力が戻らずそのまま難聴者になれ
これを突発性難聴
ています
柏浜佐美さんだったり
いろんな方がまた話をしてみても取り上げられる形になりました
またもう一つこれは非常に問題になっています
弁当範疇ですね
ある
アメリカの学校では入学した大学生の半数近くがすでに
樽仕な巨ヘッドホン難聴になっているという話を聞いていますそれぐらい
館長がよ待っているという感じです
また日本にはどれくらい気候に慣れている方
南中の方もいらっしゃると思いますか
2013年日本の軟調させるんですけども約1500万に行くでおります
65歳以上の半数の方へ
これはに超高齢者によって
お年を避けることで
レベルと言われております
またご存知の理論ずですが
ウジェバトライプって言う
8ゲートデータがあるんですけど
要チェキは目覚ましい技術革新をして本ですけどもなかなか日本の蒸気
農業を張っていていないということがこれでわかっています欧米に比べても半数がです
ね
非常に低いことがずっと続いております
また
これよくいらっしゃいます
福祉施設だったり病院に行ったり
自然主義と呼びます
優しさ難聴の人と話す場合は
大きな声でゆっくり話せば大丈夫でと言うという
実は味源ですね
難聴には実の種類がありますね
落ち目でと3つあるんですけれども
表示します
ランチョーは現在ましてまずは
ego 西南女
あとは可能性なんて靴ですよ
縫合男女というのがあります
この顔も性難聴というのが非常にやっぱりです
大きいほどでも聞こえが改善しないですね
こちらビジュアルで説明していますけれども音が聞こえることと男として認識すること
は違うんです
これ画像を言いますけど最近デジカメっていうのは非常に良くなりましたピンクを
見せることありませんけども
リっぽくしたなどを大きくして大
見えません
同じように
音も同じなんですね
ピンボケするのにちゃんと#ですピントを合わせておけば聞こえはいい
大きくしましても経営
いいということがありますこれ画像も同じですね
なので私は研究室では帰ってきたのがご縁のもうしただけではないです
いかにフリー会い話をしてあげるかということが大事になります
また一つ研究教えて分かりました
人は
痛がりなどうずればいい
話したがれたと思うんです
次のアンケートをいれば凄く良く上がっていただき
こちらは第一生命
第一清兵衛経済研究所の底安定とデータですけども
難聴者とのコミュニケーション書に関するないんです
まず
情報を正しく伝えるのに
非常に難しい
話すときは自分の口調がきつくなりやすい
話と時間がかかった完全にこれ話すがうのあるんですよね力欲望ですよね
伝わってほしいというまさにこのデータを見ても伝えないです
難聴の人たちにスタート美味しいです県庁舎のはこれでわかっていただけると思い
その中で
これまでは難聴の方がの状況をつけるなり人工内耳を装用する直して頑張ってました
しかしながら先ほど言ったように大きな声でぺするわけがありません
そういったことが分かってきて話す側がいかにクリアーなことを届ける買って作った
ものがこのコミュはれているものです
下旬な店長者が難聴者に開業している世界初のシステムになります
歩いて松月庵ですよ
グッドデザインベストにあっいただきます犠牲者ですね
てこのコミュの聞こえの支援のでなりそうなんですけども3つあります
ポイントは5本聴取に最適の客せいでまぁ
セールつ以上が号名誉とに
非常に大きな影響を及ぼしますこの部分を追わず壁ていると室内でのことの話ですね
この辺を反射しています
音は340メートル秒していきますので除いた5年半少稲荷防ぐかということが難聴の
方に聞こえに
だいたいせつつありますまた音の歪みです
極限まで制する1性がありますことが多くすると歪んでいます
僕の濃い目は大きするというものがもしかしたら分かる人もめげない語ろう
を感じていただいているかも知れませ
こちらが音の音周波数の帯域のところです
先月以上のところ幅と方の構造であることによって
クリアーを当日
それではどういうところで公民が使われているかと言うところお話しさせていただき
たいと思います
こちら九州大学耳鼻咽喉科で使っていただきますけれども子供も返事ブロックの様ご
夫婦が一つのいいからになることを期待
病院ではすでにいい
数台とういただいて外来の時の会
患者さんとのお話に使っていただきます
またこちらは京都銀行冊目
本当にいい子さんの方でも窓口お話ですね
平野降ったりとか金融系の話をすると良いというのはあの時に聴いてなかったできませ
んので切開部分がに
この媚を売って対応されています
はいこちら学校ですこりゃ熊本のやつようにやるわけですけれども
これ実はドリルの鉄道します
感じというです聞こえの努力ですね
て後ろ校長先生です
やってるんですけども通常と同じカセで流した時の音でも1人と
コミュンってやっと次のフェースですね
15点から20点違います
これは能力じゃないですちょうどですね
能力は後に[ __ ]ウクが扱いにくくて点数が分からないということが置かれて先生が
pick しこんなに違う半立ちに驚かれている写真ですね
英語社交家庭ですねええ
どうしますこういうお茶の間のだんだんの時に日常の対応しているに
今日は空洞ないだろう
言えます
いづらいですよね普通の音量で普通にお話ではありませんか
だけどね先生の話がという
大きな声
怒られるかというかの迫っています実際に子さん達も
大きな声で話されるとすごく嫌がるお子さんたちような負債ということがわかります
普通の音声音量でコミュニケーションを楽しみいただいているところもあります
こちらは本当ですね先日ろう学校の本日は寄贈させていただきました
実は
2の方は ng オーガー
盗聴器を実は起動したりしているんです
しかしながらを長期はベンチでおります
電池が無くなったら
なので電池がいらない完成度はですね
なぜ5人もぜひちょっとー
そしてほしいという形でも出たところの通りです
先生が後ろ向いてお話をしているんですけれども
育児ですなんでもない飛行場たってこと
日くるんだった
ん
先ほどお話しましたけれども聞こえのインフラ整備が進んでいるけど僕はチャレンジ
可能な社会になっているなっていくと
ブービーいく能力思考力しまった
思います
影響していただいた方にぜひところは多いでいただくためを磨いていただきたいんです
けども聞こえにくい方と話をするときに
もしコミュがないば私たちもできることがあります
法律ですね相手に取る大きさがまず国にします
両方が浅く遊ぶさきっかけしましょうね合計すぎますか
結局ですかーっていう話だ
ことできるだけ騒がしい所に避けます
居酒屋とかつの特に個室を僕が協力してあげたり押しますね鈴川ところ
やる
photo by 思って発揮しを受けてお話です
独身的で土を読んだりしてますのでぜひしてません
ますが外してください
これなかなか皆さん理解できないんですけどマスクを外していただきて口の形ようで
いただくことが必要です
と後ろから声をかける場合は肩をトントンでももっと疲れ様際に気づきませんか
別に無視してるわけじゃないんですよ
気付かしてあげてください
ぜひこれは明日からと評価がございます
再生してください
こちらがあっ
山本自身大変な被害に遭われた方
ところ
ていますけれども
こちら今日会場に入ってるんですけども愛知熊さんという方の工さん達です
僕は浜本地震が起きた後にチーム4とだけ言いました
私は忘れなかったのは h です人工内耳の電子展示がなくなると伝えません
なのであと何自分あるんですが電池はあと3日分知らないでとか坊主つけてます
ただポーズつけていると方向がわかりません
こっちの油絵のハイこっち粋な説より読者はありません
そのもう中ですね危ない非常に合うい r で僕は天地を届けていきます
これまでプロげな子
増強は刷毛ですねなんかおじいちゃんの指定
10秒近くです
最後になります
本年度4月障害者差別解消法というのがございました
条件の合う人もない人も働きやすい
環境をつくっていこうと友情が支え法律になります
なかなかやめ聞こえについては理解されない環境ですがどんどんこのボール2きっかけ
に来行為に対して意識を高めることができるようになればなと
私は狙っていただけませんぜひ今日お話しを聞いて頂いたみなさん
表記声の話を覚えてますよね
意識が深まったと思いますのでぜひとも私が発動しているの
いろんな活動に対して協力してくださいそうすればまだ世の中から世界が終わっている
と思います
ぜひとも協力お願いしますご清聴はやりました